I am thrilled to see so many people here
on a Thursday evening and I actually
just so that we can understand our
marketing efforts a little bit better I
would love to know just a show of hands
Stanford GSB students if I can see where
the GSB students are excellent excellent
greetings in the balcony Stanford
undergrad students welcome we love
having you here
members of the rest of the Stanford
community faculty staff alumni that's
just think and from the Harvard
community who has joined us besides our
speaker welcome we are delighted that
you're here
tonight is a chance for two great
schools to come together and we are
delighted for the evening that we are
going to spin with you my name is JD
Schrom I am a faculty member here at the
GSB I teach courses in communication and
I also have the privilege of leading the
mastery and communication initiative
which is a series of non-credit
offerings to help students build their
abilities to speak write and participate
more effectively behind me you will see
some of the events that are coming up
through the rest of the quarter if you
don't have the moment to write them down
quickly you can go to our website which
you simply GSB dot stanford.edu
backslash mastery and that will open up
the world of mastery and communication
to you when we were looking for a
speaker for this evening we really want
to define somebody who had made their
success because of their ability to
communicate effectively and last year I
had the privilege of seeing Sal Khan at
the TED conference some speak at a
company here in the Bay Area we began
our dialogue to have him come in before
I introduce the student who will
introduce Sal to you there's one event
in particular that I want to be sure
that I mentioned to you and that is that
we have a viewing of the TED conference
this year it will happen from February
28th to March 2nd and we have a site
license to broadcast the full TED
conference here to the GSB to our GSB
students
encourage you to sign up by going to our
website you'll also see information
about it in the distributions that come
out to you through email but that is
we're excited about having that event
here you did not come here tonight to
hear from a professor you came to hear
from an entrepreneur and so to introduce
him I'm delighted to welcome to the
stage Luke Pena Luke is a second year
MBA student in the joint degree program
between the school of ed and the School
of Business and Luke if you could come
forward from age 8 to age 13 my home was
my classroom and I was my own teacher
now I have the privilege of standing
before you as Luke pena joints MBA ma
education degree student co-president of
the Stanford education club and proof
that non-traditional students can find
the path to success it's my great honor
and privilege to welcome you all here
tonight and my responsibility to remind
you to please not use your cell phones
and computers during tonight's event
back to the classroom of my youth I was
a hyperactive child with a hyperactive
mind traditional schools evaluated me
and determined that I would require
either medication or special education
courses my mother disagreed so my mother
decided to home-school me and serving as
my teacher through the 5th grade I took
tests every year to make sure that I was
performing at or above the level of my
peer group in traditional schools when
my mother decided to return to
undergraduate school to pursue her
degree I became my own teacher and for
the next five years I relied on a
variety of non-traditional education
resources to guide my learning without
access to these resources I would never
have found my own passion for education
I would have never survived grade school
and I would have never found my way here
to Stanford I know that there are
countless other students traditional and
non-traditional
who require and desire and desperately
need these innovative resources to
create their own education opportunities
Khan Academy is creating these very
opportunities for students around the
globe along the way Khan Academy is
redefining the very way we think about
teaching about learning and about
education the organization is committed
to changing education for the better by
providing a free world-class education
anywhere anytime the Khan Academy
website now provides self-pacing
software and includes over 3000
instructional videos on its YouTube
channel covering everything from basic
arithmetic to college-level science and
economics it's the most used library of
educational videos on the web with 3.7
million unique students per month over
88 million lessons delivered and over
260 million exercises completed a
growing number of classrooms around the
world are relying on Khan Academy to
build student mastery of topics and to
create space in class for dynamic
project-based learning Khan Academy owes
its success to its founder Salman Khan
Khan was helping a young cousin with
math in 2004 communicating by phone and
using an interactive notepad when others
expressed interest he began posting his
hands purple tutorials on YouTube and
demand took off before founding Khan
Academy he was the portfolio manager at
Khan Capital Management and the senior
analyst at wool capital management Saul
received his MBA from Harvard Business
School where he was president of the
student body he also holds a master's in
electrical engineering and computer
science a BS in electrical engineering
and computer science and a BS in
mathematics from MIT where he was
president of the class of 1998 while at
MIT
Saul was the recipient of the Elrond to
fellowship which he used to develop
web-based math software for children
with ADHD children not unlike myself
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Sal Khan
Thank You vice
this is very exciting so sorry how many
of you all have been to the site or have
used the site and some way shell good so
this is this is a good good good
audience so I guess how many of you have
not been to the site or oh good good so
I have something to show you
so for those of you who have not been to
the site I have a little montage that
shows what what the videos look like
well we'll see over the course of this
and I actually do want to make it as
much of a conversation as possible
there's microphones and all the rest I'm
gonna talk for like I don't know 10 or
15 minutes and then I just want to have
questions comments anything else but
we'll see it's Khan Academy is actually
much more than than just the library of
videos that initially I started creating
and now we have a few other people
working on as well but I'll let me just
oh yes there's other things happening in
the background okay all right very good
so here we go the notation usually is a
capital Sigma all of these interactions
are just do the gravity over
interstellar or almost you could call it
integral acting so the right slot is I
plus one this animals fossils are only
found in this area of South America nice
clean band here they create the
Committee of Public Safety which sounds
like a very nice committee notice this
is an aldehyde and it's an alcohol it's
some type of an infectious disease
exactly so the key is when you start to
look at data you have to look at all
aspects of it ours is there 30 million
plus the 20 million dollars from the
American manufacturer if this does not
blow your mind then you have no emotion
well educated audience you appreciate
Oilers identity and of the French
Revolution that's very good so just to
get you up to speed and a little bit of
this was covered in the introduction and
this this slide and actually some of the
data from the introduction was a few
months old and this is old to what we're
actually now pushing about five million
unique students a month they're doing
two million exercises a day actually and
growing and you know out in Silicon
Valley we get used a million here
million there oh you know that's not so
exciting until you get to ten million or
whatever else but but an education these
really are large numbers and you know
I didn't do that to pick on Harvard but
but that is and actually since these
numbers are old where now it on a
monthly basis we are serving six to
seven times the number of students that
that Harvard has served since 1636 and
we're growing 400% a year so it's you
know we'll see we'll see where that goes
but before we go in kind of the present
of what Khan Academy is up to I want to
talk a little bit about how it happened
because it's it's you know I still kind
of wake up in the middle of the night
and and wonder about this very strange
journey that you're kind of catching me
hopefully in the middle of or maybe very
close to the beginning of hopefully it's
been good so far
as was introduced 2004 I had just gotten
married I was a newly minted MBA
graduate in 2003 was working in Boston
as an analyst at a hedge fund and I had
family visiting me from neurons right
after my wedding in New Jersey they came
up to Boston my 12 year old cousin Nadia
her younger brother Armand was two years
younger than and then the youngest Ali
and I showed him all the sights in
Boston and I was very impressed with
Nadia I hadn't seen her since I had left
from I grew up in New Orleans where
since I was in high school so which was
like 2 or 3 years old and now she was 12
years old super smart girl and I kept
encouraging as I call you know you
should really you know think about some
of these fancy schools that are in town
and all the rest and her mom told me one
morning before Nadia had woken up that
this is very nice and naughty of you you
as an older brother figure in all the
rest but she's actually having trouble
with mathematics and I I had trouble
believing this you know this you know
one I we were having conversations and
she seemed at least you know super she
intimidated me and on half the
conversations and on top of that you
know we shared a certain amount of DNA
and so so I told Nutter than Tina his
mother that you know I find that hard to
believe and when Nadia woke up I said
well what's going on and she said I took
a placement exam and I there's unit
conversion ounces to gallons killing
you know kilometres meters miles things
like that and she says I just don't get
that I you know my brain just checks out
and I told I was like look Nadia I've
had conversations with you the last few
days we were in did I remember did some
brain teasers where we were waiting for
the fireworks over the Charles River and
I said
all of that stuff that we've been
talking about is ten times deeper and
more conceptual that than units and I
and I'm not saying this just as a kind
of a pep talk you you can do this and
and you know I think like a lot of not
just children frankly people who've
disengaged with with some content they
appreciate the pep talk but they're like
oh okay you know that's nice but you
know it probably doesn't apply to me and
so I said well let's make this happen
you go back to New Orleans that they
still live in New Orleans and every day
after work I'll we'll get on something
we'll get on a conference phone and
we'll use Yahoo doodle or something and
and and we'll work together and and she
agreed I think she was skeptical but she
says oh you know I have this cousin kind
of an older brother figure who wants to
spend time with me worth a try and long
story short you know they went back to
New Orleans
she she started working together the
first month was hard but but she
eventually did get past that and then we
started just doing random topics algebra
here there and she actually became an
advanced math student and then I I kind
of I I I've coined the phrase I became
somewhat of a tiger cousin and I perhaps
better than a tiger mom and I called her
school I said she should retake the exam
you don't understand what she's
accomplished there was some resistance
on that part and and and I'm like those
and you know her mom isn't telling me
it's I'm telling and and but she was
able to take it and she took the exam
and actually she ended becoming a very
advanced math student she ended up
taking calculus her freshman year in
high school she ended up taking math at
University of New Orleans through most
of high school so she became this really
advanced math student that same student
and who thought she couldn't get units
but but I was excited you know my day
job I wasn't able to exercise some of
these these same ideas so I started
tutoring her brothers things started to
go well with them
then I you know would call up random
family members and say well can I tutor
your kids and and there was kind of a
tone like Oh things must not be going so
well at the hedge fund looking for a
backup job which is kind of true I guess
but but but so that's already happened
and you fast forward to 2006 and I had a
cohort of about 15 or 18 yeah about 15
to 20 family friends and relatives
around the country that I was tutoring
after work and and it was interesting I
mean we but it wasn't as good as those
interactions with nod there was one on
one I started writing a little bit of
kind of fairly primitive software
initially so that I could give them
example problems I could keep track of
what they were doing I mean it's amazing
when you as soon as you keep track of
things and you see the real-time data
you start saying why is that Lee doing
problems at 3:00 in the morning this is
you know irrespective of algebra this is
an issue but but but uh I started doing
that in 2006 the firm I was working for
actually I was working at wool capital
management it was a a two-person and a
dog firm the the dog was our chief
economist and and Dan's wife who Dan was
my boss his wife became a professor at
Stanford Law School and so we moved the
firm out to Palo Alto actually was on
Menlo Park and and I was based out here
and in 2006 I was having dinner in San
Mateo with a with a buddy from from
college and you know I was showing him
the software that I was building and it
gave you hints and generated problems
and I was telling him about all these
bit you know I actually I wasn't making
videos yet I was telling him about these
tutoring sessions I was doing and I told
him I only frustration is is that now
when I do these sessions I do a session
with Sasha I'm like oh I wish he was
there when I covered that same material
with Arman or with Nadia last week or
last year a lot of times when I when I
did these video tutorials you know I
would ask them oh you know did you get
this does this make sense to you and
there would be kind of just you know
pregnant pause and they would say yeah
yeah I get it I get it and you know they
did it but you didn't want to push the
issue and make them feel weird about it
and all the rest they just didn't want
waste of my time and you you would have
these things happening there was a sense
that they they had basic questions but
they were afraid to ask
you know they forgot how to divide
decimals even though they're in ninth
grade and they didn't want to embarrass
themselves because I've been telling
them that you're smart and you can do
all of these things and my buddy he told
me well well you know there's this thing
called YouTube why don't you make some
tutorials on YouTube and and put them up
there and you know my initial reaction I
know that doesn't make any sense you
know YouTube is for cats playing piano
it's
not for for serious mathematics but but
then I went home that weekend and I and
I and I got over the idea that that it
wasn't my idea
which which is hard for an MBA sometimes
it's easy and I gave it a shot and I
know I was funny you can you can look at
those first videos there that are I mean
literally in November 2006 least common
multiples some basic algebra things like
that and interesting things started to
happen I I won I pointed my cousins and
family friends these people I was
tutoring I pointed them to the videos
and I said what do you think of them and
you know I joke a lot about this if any
of y'all saw the TED talk I talked about
this do but it was absolutely true the
first feedback they gave me was that
they preferred me on youtube than in
person and I still haven't clarified how
broad of a statement that is if it's
just you know math math videos or not
but but but that meant a lot and and all
of these ideas of when the live session
being afraid to ask questions being
afraid to admit that you might have
forgotten something before being afraid
to ask this person you respect and this
person who respects you asking them to
repeat something you're afraid you're
wasting them time now all of a sudden
they had it all on demand they can pause
and repeat as much as they want and they
could watch it they could watch it when
they're ready for it I when we were
doing the live sessions there's a huge
value there and we'll talk about that in
the future we think that a lot of what
we're doing is it going to only enhance
the live session I was taking interest
there was this bond that was forming but
the hard parts were after work some
buddies I wasn't on my a-game I had a
bad day at work or whatever and and many
times I you know I could imagine Navia
the girl the guy that she had a crush on
asked some other girl to the prom and
she's just depressed and she's not that
interested in the least common multiple
or whatever whatever else and so that
was a pretty interesting thing so I just
kept making more and more videos my wife
at this point was a medical resident so
I had a lot of time on my hands and and
the videos were out there I kept doing
more and more videos and then like I
guess a lot of stories like this I
started to realize that people that I
was not related to were watching the
videos and you know the initial comments
were things like thank you or this
really helped and
don't know how much time y'all have
spent on YouTube but but most of the
comments aren't quite positive if you're
if you're g-rated for that matter but
but so just that that thank you this
helped but then started to get comments
coming in and as the traffic grew the
comments got more and more we get a
higher volume and then we start getting
really touching comments my children
have dyslexia my children have ADHD and
this is the only thing that's getting
through to them I got a letter early on
from a from a kid who's about to drop
out of high school and he said this was
these YouTube videos were the only thing
that got him to re-engage with the
content early on I got a letter from a
parent saying that they are praying for
me and and and you know I was an analyst
at a hedge fund it wasn't this was other
than my investors I don't think there
was much prayer going on so so uh so I
just kept going and and that was the
other discovery that that's started to
happen is that this wasn't you know when
you look at an algebra textbook in a
calculus textbook there are these
thousands of pages and all of that you
immediately sue them out there's you
know I can just make a dent in that
there's no way I could cover but you
have like 70 or 80 videos hey that's a
pretty good scaffold of algebra there's
now like you know 600 or something on
the site but that was a pretty good
scaffold of algebra to do a few more
that's pretty good scaffold of of
calculus and you start realizing that in
a lot of the world people say oh you
should focus on platform not content
content doesn't scale but education
content really does scale as it's done
once it can be used forever calculus
isn't changing every every three years
as the the textbook publishers would
have you believe so so so it just kept
going and by 2009 frankly I had trouble
focusing on my day job and I was working
at an another fund out here in Palo Alto
connective capital and so I you know
that introduction there was a brief
moment of con capital but it never got
beyond cons capital so I kind of which
wasn't significant by the way I'm
dressed you can tell but the the so I
had trouble focusing on my day job and
so I kind of had to sit down with my
wife and we figured out well someone's
got to realize this is like the highest
possible social return on investment
that just worked for one
guy's salary or whatever you can educate
at that point I think we were getting
all ready we had on the order of about a
million students per month actually oh
no we had a several hundred thousand
students per month but that could only
grow over time and even if I got hit by
a bus these videos in theory could keep
teaching and if we could build out a
platform in a virtual school we could
reach an infinite number of students and
and translate in all the rest and so
somewhat naively I'd already set up Khan
Academy as a not-for-profit
and I'm happy to answer any questions
about why why we decided to do that but
uh so I decided to take the leap of
faith I had no experience really
starting a not-for-profit even how do
you raise money for not for any of that
but it was just this idea that someone
should hopefully realize that this is
worth doing and so like a lot of I think
entrepreneurial stories for-profit or
not-for-profit you quit there's always a
few leads that you think oh those are
gonna happen next week and then they
don't and and and about eight months
into it you start getting really
stressed and and I started updating my
resume and you know seeing if the the
hedge fund world would have me back
after I completely flaked out
god forbid starting a not-for-profit and
but then something interesting happened
I had this little link on the site
PayPal link college students around the
world where you know they're giving $10
$5 which which meant a lot but all of a
sudden a $10,000 donation came in all
over PayPal and so I checked who it was
and and it was a it was a woman by the
name of and or and so I immediately
email her back and she was actually I
saw the address who's in Palo Alto and I
said well you know thank you it if if we
were a physical school you would now
have a building named after you if is uh
which is and talking to the folks here I
hear that's a very good deal I don't
think $10,000 quite quite cuts it in its
maybe the podium not even yeah water
fountain yeah but so so an and
immediately e-mails back and says whoa
I'd be interested in talking to you so
we literally we met it at one of the
Indian buffets on University Ave and she
says well where are you going with this
what do you want to do well and and and
her first question actually was how are
you supporting yourself and you know and
is proud away as possible I said I'm not
and she kind of nodded and she said well
were you hoping to take this and I had
these
I had these slides I said well we could
build out the software that I started
with my cousin's and we could we could
reach more students we could translate
it we could have interactivity on the
site we could do as much as possible
creating a real virtual interactive
experience and she kind of nodded and
then you know I got back in my car and
and actually got on her bike she rode
her bike to the buffet which I was very
impressed and and when I was driving
into my driveway I got a I got a text
message from an and and it said you
should be supporting yourself I just
wired you $100,000 so so it was a good
day almost almost crashed into the into
the garage and as we'll see in the story
and text messages are always good things
so this was this wasn't that long ago
this was literally about not not even
two years ago this was May of 2010 and
right around that same time that you a
few weeks later but these were all kind
of unrelated events some folks that
Google brought me in you know I say
there's two major institutions in
Mountain View Google and the Khan
Academy and we it's the and and they
brought me and II and it was kind of a
mysterious meeting they said you know a
lot of our children are using your stuff
we even use some of your finest stuff
it's interesting for us what would you
do if you had more resources and I I
kind of made the same pitch and they all
nodded and and then you know I kind of
assumed and I by this point I spoke into
many foundations and I've become fairly
cynical about things I was like okay you
know this isn't gonna work out but at
least and I can continue to do this and
pay my mortgage and whatever else and
then in July of that year so this is
July of 2010 I was running a little
summer camp for it was actually in
Portola Valley and I had this little
game it was mainly for middle school
students six of the students were
playing a game of Risk and then the
other 20 students were trading
securities based on the outcome of the
game of Risk and and while that was
happening literally a trading floor it's
a very good game actually maybe the
business school should look into but but
the while that was happening I got a
text message from an and and the text
you know text messages they're kind of
hard to figure out which one came first
and all the rest but it was like Bill
Gates
600 people Aspen talking about you and I
was like and those people that Bill
Gates would talk about so maybe this was
you know some type of she wouldn't have
a she didn't seem much like much of a
prankster here but I was like is you
know what's going on here so I
immediately I went on to and I voted the
nearest seventh grader off of a computer
and I said what's going on here and and
I people were already commenting and
blogging and been putting it on Twitter
Bill Gates in front of he was in the at
you know Aspen ideas festival in a stage
you know on the main whatever pavilion
he just started talking for 10 minutes
about how he and his children were using
the Khan Academy and it was like the one
thing that he was most excited about and
my brain immediately said those videos
were for Nadia not for Bill not for Bill
Gates this is you know I have to really
rethink some of those but but but then
and it was and and I mean the video is
actually up on our site now it was very
surreal and I didn't see it that first
day I saw it a few days later when the
video actually got posted and then I was
in this very strange surreal world
because this event happened someplace in
reality but I was like what do I do now
do I call him you know is this is this a
you know I can I find his number I don't
think so it's and and and but luckily
that kind of tension got alleviated
about two weeks later I got a call from
I guess Larry Cohen who was able to find
my number and the Bill Gates is chief of
staff and he says you know Bill you
probably heard is a big fan he's as your
stuff he actually told me that bill has
three monitors and I've seen it and
apparently Khan Academy is like he's
regularly watching videos on there and
and he's like you know if you have time
do it bill would like to meet you
and I was looking at my you know I had
my calendar open for the whole month
right
and it's completely blank and so so I
was like yeah you know maybe like next
Wednesday 2:45 I could fly right into
Seattle and you know right in between a
bath and you know laundry I can squeeze
squeeze Bill Gates in and and so I flew
up to Seattle met with Bill Gates which
was surreal meeting you know 20% of my
brain was in the meeting the other 80%
was this is Bill Gates that's Bill Gates
what would happen if I hit him what
would happen if I I didn't want to but
you you could imagine the so but but you
know I presented and you know there was
there was an awkward moment where I had
I had these I called him my slide
placemats and I walked around and I was
like oh you know I used these you know I
don't trust PowerPoint these things were
always been I think he found me charming
but a but you know long story short he
said oh well you know this this makes
sense I'm a big fan what would you do I
give it a week of virtual school and all
the rest and and he's like no this this
is great and he nodded and when he
nodded five people in the back of the
room took notes and it's like a good
show make sure you got that and and so
it looked like things were going good
and right around that same time another
meeting with Google Google said well
what would you do at two million dollars
and I said you know is this an open
question cuz you know I've got needs you
know I could and they clarified it and
and and and so I kind of I I kind of
made the same the same idea and so
October 2010 all of these things
converge the Gates Foundation funded us
to really get office space higher up our
core team Google funded us translated
into 10 languages build out the core
software and this is what we've started
to build and actually some of this was
already you know the primitive version
was there before the funding happened
but now we got essentially competent
people to work on to work on some of
this stuff and this is what we call a
knowledge map and it's constantly
changing there's like 60 nodes right
here it's now 300 and we're exploring
different ways to visualize this right
now but but the idea is very simple that
top that top star there is the most
basic mathematics level one edition and
once
you get once you've shown proficiency
that it moves you down this knowledge
map and right now at the bottom end of
it you have things like a calculus and
and and whatever else and and actually
we can see it so this is one for getting
the intuition of a derivative where
you're trying to do where you take the
slope of the tangent line at any point
and you're in sexually plotting out the
derivative by picking out the slope of
the tangent line and so we're trying to
make that knowledge map go as broad and
deep as possible our videos you saw they
go into things like finance and macro
and microeconomics and thinking you know
and leaving there's a little bit of
medicine and things like that but right
now our exercises are mostly math but
we're hoping to get that is as broad and
as deep as possible and this right over
here is a more basic one and if you have
need help the videos are there
this is your basic subtraction literally
and and and you know the one thing I
always emphasize I talked a lot about
this in the TED talk is we did this kind
of the waist common sense you know if
you learned if you went to music class
you won't take do a harder piece until
you do fit master and easier piece if
you're in Taekwondo you don't take the
black belt test until you're already I
don't know the what is a brown belt or a
green belt or whatever you you only
progress once you're ready for it and
isn't and that's how it works in video
games and everything else but that's not
how it works in a traditional academic
model in a traditional academic model
what is fixed is how long you have to
learn something and when you have to
learn something and what's variable is
how well you actually learn that topic
and in everything else and I would say
natural learning and in this we just
said let's do the opposite let's make
variable when you learn it and how long
you have to learn it and what's fixed is
a high level of mastery so that you can
build on that foundation I mean the
analogy I say in the traditional
academic model and it's not picking on
anyone it's the model that we've all
been frankly indoctrinated into is I'm
building a house I lay the foundation I
go get the inspector to come by and the
the inspector says okay yeah this
foundation is about 80% structurally
sound and I said great that's passing
let's build the first floor and then
they do the first floor or 70% oh that's
passing let's build a second floor and
then when the fourth floor collapses and
takes the whole thing down with it I
blame the fourth floor contractor
instead of saying what I had these gaps
this whole time that we're just making
my whole building less and less
structurally sound and that's exactly
happening
frankly with math education but I think
probably with most forms of education
especially things that assume some level
of mastery of of more basic ideas so we
we started up we got our office base and
an interesting you know and as you can
see a lot of this stuff was unplanned
serendipitous events right when we got
our office space actually right before
we got our office space the Los Altos
School Board right here Los Altos said
hey we heard you're doing some stuff
why don't you come meet us so we met
them and there's like what would you do
if you could do anything you wanted with
a fifth grade classroom and we said well
we would have every student learning at
their own pace they would master
concepts before moving on and the role
of the teacher instead of giving this
one size one pace fits all lecture the
teacher would get data would get
analytics so that they can do focused
one-on-one interventions or even better
they can pair up students with each
other so that they can teach each other
and get get even deeper learning and
kind of surprising they two days later
said sounds good well what started after
Thanksgiving and so we had to hire up a
little bit and so this right here is a
dashboard from that Los Altos pilot and
we're constantly iterating and trying to
improve these things but the general
model is each column here is one of
those concepts on that knowledge map
each row here is one of the students in
the class green means and actually
there's a fancier version of this now
this was a few months ago green means
the students proficient in it blue means
are working on it but no need to worry
and red means they're stuck so the model
is hey instead of one size fits all
lecture why don't I get that why don't I
get one of those students who've already
mastered exponents level three to tutor
this student right over here who's
having trouble with it and if they if
that doesn't work than I the teacher can
go do a focused one-on-one intervention
and what's neat about it is and we're
actually seeing this in the classroom is
it's optimizing the most scarce resource
in the classroom which is actually the
time with other human beings and so now
you know people talk about Steiger to
teacher-student ratio what we think
we're optimizing is that the the student
to valuable time with the teacher ratio
or even better the student to valuable
time with other human beings rate ratio
because you also have the other the
other peers that you're learning from
and actually one of the pilots it was
interesting the teacher spent a
significant amount of time mentoring a
subset of the fifth graders as tas fifth
graders stas and we wanted to arm them
with as much data as possible and so it
should not freeze like this let me see
well there's a very nice chart that
shows up all right let's try this again
oh there you go so this tells us a
teacher of what the students been
working on actually students have access
to all of these things and we found it
the best way to teach elementary school
students to read bar graphs is to make
the bar graphs about them we are we are
all narcissists inside yeah this tells a
student a parent a teacher and all of
this is free it's all available right
now you can go via come your cousin's or
your nephews or coaches right now this
tells the teacher what a student's been
focused on videos and exercises you can
drill down as much as you want
this gives granular data on exactly what
problem the students did when now we
have features you can click on you can
actually see the narrative of that
problem what the students what choices
they got wrong what did it get right
what hints did they use and this right
here is just another dashboard for
teachers but for us it tells us kind of
the most powerful narrative here and
something frankly we didn't expect is
that the horizontal axis here is just
days working on the site vertical axis
is just a count of the number of those
modules that a student shows proficiency
and so each of those lines is
essentially the progression of a student
in the class and what we're seeing in
every class were working with in Los
Altos and Los Altos regular classes and
all salsals remedial classes in San Jose
and in East Palo Alto when you start a
class right at the beginning there's
some kids that race ahead some kids in
the middle and some kids that are behind
in a traditional model like okay these
are the kids they're gonna be you know
doctors engineers lawyers they're gonna
you know apply to Stanford all the rest
these are average kids these kids are
the remedial kids but what we're seeing
is if you allow students to work at
their own pace at their own time and you
don't know who these students are it's
really unpredictable we're gonna try to
fine-tune the analytics so we can
predict us even better if you give them
the chance to to build their foundation
start from 1+1 all of a sudden that
student and that blue student is one of
them ten days into it's slightly below
average actually right out the gate a
reasonable bit below average after 70
something days best student in the class
and we're seeing it over and over again
in every context
that after two three-four months the
best dude in the class is often a kid
that you thought was a remedial student
2-3 months ago and we're seeing it over
and over and over again and just to give
you an a sense of the energy of these
classrooms because sometimes when you
know you say all computer learning
blended learning people imagine kind of
a Vulcan Borg reality of kind of things
plugged in look you know in kids just
doing this all day and and I'll show you
this classroom actually even this
classroom the visuals aren't exactly
because whenever the press tries to take
it they're like oh well this is what the
program is so I want to we want to film
kids doing the program we're like no no
what's cool about this is because this
is 10 20 30 % of class time it frees up
all this other time for peer to peer
tutoring for project-based learning
whatever else but the media always wants
to get the kids actually on the computer
so that what there is that in this
footage but it does capture the energy
level in these classrooms from Mountain
View California NBC's Kristen Welker has
our story tonight what makes fifth
graders cheer would you believe that
these kids are learning with the help of
Khan Academy in online school you got it
right good job videos that are
interactive and fun explaining difficult
concepts in a conversational way and
there's a fun story that came out of
that actual when that reporter visited
that classroom she saw a little fifth
grader working on on trigonometry you
know normally 11th grade 12th grade type
of material but she was you know she was
assigned cosine tangent she understood
the ratios of the triangle so reporter
sits down next to her and says so do you
think this is 5th grade math and the
girl got a very mischievous grin on her
face and she goes no I think it's sixth
grade
so you know the anecdotal stuff was
great the teachers were happy the
students were happy but but they're you
know we start to measure at least
measure make sure harm isn't being done
here because you know there are these
state tests this is a public school
we're not teaching to the test in the
videos I don't use necessarily the same
words that are going to show up on the
assessment there are kids in those
classrooms that are doing 4th grade math
there's kids in those classrooms doing
10th 11th grade math and how are they
gonna perform on a 5th grade assessment
or in one of the pod cases of 7th grade
assessment and we were particularly
worried about the 7th graders the 5th
graders was standard Los Altos
demographic high-performing School
District the 7th the to 7th grade
classes that piloted it
these were it wasn't Los Altos which is
a fluent school district but this was a
remedial math class in Los Altos and
most of these students in this class
we're students who are either diagnosed
with learning disabilities you know
dyslexia ADHD and many of them were
essentially from the other side of El
Camino they were essentially part of the
parts of Mountain View that were thrown
into the Los Altos School District so
these these were actually traditionally
underperforming students and what was
neat is we saw that narrative again and
we were worried about this because like
our product is new we don't want to be
you know blamed too you know maybe they
won't work with this group of students
but what was amazing for us and frankly
for Los Altos the district is that this
is where we saw some of the most
profound gains so what we saw 2010 were
was the distribution of scores for this
for this cohort entering in 23% were
proficient and they were the low end of
proficient that's why they were in this
class 47% were basic 23% below basic 6%
far below basic and then after six
months and this is exciting the six plus
35 41% were now proficient or better and
the whole curve had shift there were no
longer any far below basic the whole
distribution shifted in the right
direction
but what was really neat and what we had
never expected what the Los Altos had
never expect it is this was a remedial
math class some of these kids diagnosed
with learning disabilities 6% of these
kids were now advanced 6% of these kids
had leapfrogged ahead of students who
were not placed in remedial math class
and there was no way frankly of
predicting who they were until we
frankly we saw the data and you know
normally these classes are kind of the
graveyard of your academic career but it
actually
was able to accelerate these students so
the last thing I want to share with you
and and I have a couple other sides of
ya asked question about them is is a is
a story we got this past summer which is
pretty exciting we got a lot of
testimonials and letters and if any of
y'all have any feel free to share it
with us it's it's good for company
morale but I want to show you something
cuz it for us it highlights how much
potential there is out in the world
human potential intellectual potential
and and how it can just be tapped into
if you just give people just just a
little bit of the right tools my name is
Mark Halberstadt growing up I was really
always a c' student I think I was really
pretty much always pretty pitiful in
school I don't think I've ever gotten
higher than a B+ in any math class ever
particularly I pretty much thought that
the only thing I was good enough to do
in college was major in music and I went
off and I got a music degree in
saxophone but I sort of almost felt it
was more I was getting it because I was
terrible at everything else kind of
worked as a saxophone player for a few
years really why I wanted to do was do
electrical engineering from the last
thing that I remember completely not
getting was trig identities so I went to
YouTube and I did a search for trig
identities and the Khan Academy was the
first thing that popped up watched a
bunch of videos and the trig playlists
to kind of get caught up to speed I
watched all the videos in the calculus
playlist I watched all the videos in the
physics playlist watched a bunch of
videos on dividing decimals and even on
a subtraction by borrowing I watched a
lot of videos on on arithmetic that was
in 2007 I did that until the fall of
2010 and in the fall 2010 I I took a
leap I decided to go go back to school
and went to Temple University majored in
electrical engineering gang a second
bachelor's and keep in mind I don't
think I've ever gotten above a B+ and
math
classes and I was really a straight C
student growing up and I just finished
this year first year back in college I
got a 4.0 GPA for the entire year I got
perfect scores on both my calc final
exams and also on my chemistry final
exam
they ended calculus chemistry both
calculus classes couple end to end
chemistry with an average higher than a
hundred percent I there are some Khan
Academy videos that I probably listen to
the same concept over 20 or 30 times and
there is no to hurt in the world I could
have paid to have sat next to me and
repeated the same thing over 20 or 30
times without at least them getting a
little bit judgmental or at least them
thinking like oh well this guy really is
never going to get this concept and he
should just give up where the
understanding really happened was
watching those videos and also working
through the Khan Academy software and
everything the impact for me in my life
I really see it growing exponentially
over the next 20 or 30 years so from the
bottom of my heart thank you
so I'd love I'd love I'd love to take
I'd love to take questions now I know
there are some people had to leave at 6
o'clock so feel free to leave if you
have to leave at 6 o'clock but I'd love
to take as many questions until they get
boring thank you so much for for joining
us I'm a Greg Bybee I'm an MBA and
Master of Education dual degree student
actually taking a class on nonprofits
and writing about Khan Academy we had to
look at the mission statement and it's
incredibly inspirational to educate
you'll free world-class education to
anyone anywhere but when thinking about
it and watching the videos and playing
with it and the TED talk a lot of what
gets me excited and has got the media
excited is the idea of blended learning
and so I was wondering do you see your
mission pivoting at all
are you still focused on global
education because I think sort of rural
kids in Africa so what if you had
another two million dollars what's next
for you where where would you go with
that mission yeah no so I mean this is
our our the most difficult thing right
now as an organization is that we have
an abundance of opportunity because
there's like okay there's the you know
just the standard student who just needs
help right like this student right here
you have the blended learning
opportunities what's happening in Los
Altos and not just Los Altos we're
seeing it at Eastside prep in East Palo
Alto at some of the charter schools Kip
there's a possibility as if you go into
rural Africa or rural India go places
where they don't have teachers right now
and all of a sudden you can give them
something better than maybe even what
they would otherwise have access to
our what what the way we we're thinking
about it right now is in the near term
let's continue to focus on these
students because out of the four point
whatever a million that are using their
this is ninety five percent of them and
this is we can reach it and we think
that that problem is ninety five percent
the same problem as how do we what what
can we do in a classroom if we can give
someone you know education is the
spectrum of things I mean and we can
debate for hours about what it means but
there's a general sense that at this end
there's kind of your core academic
skills understanding what a derivative
is learning to apply algebra
understanding the conceptual physics and
then as you get further and further here
becomes more open
and more broad you know this is starting
a company composing a sonata painting a
picture something very open-ended and
right now most schools are very focused
right over here and what we're saying is
we think this we can do this stuff
pretty well with the data and analytics
and iterate over the content but that
doesn't mean we're replacing schools
that means it's an opportunity for
schools to move up this progression and
as we get better and better we're just
gonna push the envelope here and that
the physical environments can get better
and better
and our the way we're think of it
strategically is we don't want to try to
do everything at once and just be a
flash in the pan and we want to prove
that this is real that's but you know
we're gonna start in the u.s. primarily
English although we are translating into
ten other languages right now and then
we'll explore where and they're already
frankly or NGOs I mean we heard there's
people using it in rural among I think
all of Mongolia's rural but they're
using this yeah they're you know we
heard some Burmese refugee camps where
you see I mean so this stuff is already
happening we're putting it out there
someone wants to DVD here's the DVD you
want a thumb drive with all the videos
here you go you want an offline copy
someones jury-rigged it to do that we're
open in that way but our organizational
focus right now just really make sure
that it's a it's a substantive
contribution to what happens first
around us thank you okay right here I
had two questions actually one was you
talked about capturing the potential of
human you know talent out there so the
obvious question is there are a lot more
students in the class then then teachers
in that class so how do you capture the
peer-to-peer learning because you know
kids learn better from other kids or
adults yeah the second question is do
you have any plans in terms of a
strategy to break the head yeah many of
of this content you know the nerdy
textbooks yeah Pythagoras theorem never
changed yes and yet there's copyrights
on that so how do you how do you plan to
address that because that is really what
what's holding education back in my yeah
opinion so the peer to peer which I'm a
just I mean just my own personal
experience in high school and what I'm a
big believer in peer to peer I mean I I
think y'all are probably experiencing a
lot of the learning is happening the two
nights before an exam where there's
significant peer to peer activity mostly
academic going on
and and so we're at s'what cinta
wresting about us working with physical
classrooms
you know there's 10,000 classrooms based
on our data that are doing it in some
way shape or form we're directly working
with 50 of them and we have these
notions and we're you know but the
teachers have some pretty good ideas the
students have some pretty neat ideas and
we're seeing what kind of things
naturally emerge the neat thing is is
that if you kind of allow students to
get self-directed and they're all
learning at their own pace a lot of this
stuff just organically emerges if you
don't tell as long as you just don't
tell students be quiet
put a finger on your lip listen if you
just say learn at your own pace and do
what you need to do to learn a lot of
this peer-to-peer starts emerging kid
start just naturally going to the
whiteboard this is what I can tutor you
in this is what we can help with and/or
this is what I need help in and what we
should what we're trying to do is we're
trying to observe the best practices and
seeing if we can put that in the system
so we saw students setting goals for
themselves on note cards and then seeing
how they did it so it's not let's build
that as a feature we saw students
printing out their achievements and
showing it to other friends so it's like
oh we should have public profiles if you
want to share it you can share it with
other people
so we're trying to do is if we will
eventually hopefully have a place where
if you need help there's other people in
the community who can help you you can
you know you can I have cloud cloud
tutors that at any given point someone
has office hours in that subject so
we're going to explore all of that in
terms of the the textbook industry and
you know and I say there's some what to
protect my own safety
I don't think us by ourselves as a
catalyst but I think they're they're
facing a major problem because whether
it's you look at you know either there's
kind of transitional solutions where
people are doing free books open-source
textbooks you know I think actually they
kind of signed their death certificate
when that you know they did this $15 a
textbook cannot cost more than $15 on an
iPad and and and there's no barriers to
distribution now with this size so
that's gonna bring the cost down very
quickly but I think it raises that even
broader question what does the textbook
do it does two things it tries to teach
you some new concept and right now it's
done in this very kind of cryptic prose
and then they give you some practice
problems and they give you the answer to
every other problem in the back of the
book and so we think online video
especially when you can track what's
being used how effective it is and all
the rest with analytics is better than
that prose you can pause and repeat you
get human intonation human emotion and
we think adaptive exercises where you
get data and analytics and instant
feedback and hints is better than the
the stuff at the back of the book
and if that's available for essentially
free I guess this is a case study in an
industry soon to be collapsed I guess it
sucks yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I just
wanna yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so the
question is and this is a very good
question
YouTube is a pot you know video by
itself is a one-way stream and if
someone uses it well it can be somewhat
active you can pause and repeat and you
can say oh I need to go watch that now
or not you can be a little bit
self-directed about it but it's a valid
statement it is still a passive mode and
so frankly most of our resources are
more on the interactive side the videos
are there to complement it but we are
also trying to work on things where the
videos are also giving you questions and
that there's a questions associated with
videos when you're reviewing we can give
you those conceptual questions and then
we can know hey maybe you should go
watch this video over there and the
other thing that's happened we just seen
this on YouTube is someone says oh that
was a good video I don't quite
understand what you meant by this
bi-orthogonal at minute 3 and that
someone else on YouTube says hey you
just need to go watch this other video
where it's defined a little bit more
when the videos are granular almost
every video is an answer to someone's
question and they somewhat to some
degree just have to be directed to that
answer and that's where the community
and we're just starting to explore that
yeah hi i'm Hamden and i'm at the GSB
and I'm from Bangladesh and I want to
tell you that people are mighty proud of
what you've done back home oh yeah no
it's real the day yeah I got a call from
Mohammed you guys like Mahmud so my
question is you guys are registered as a
nonprofit and a lot of people see your
biggest potential as being virtual
school or sort of spreading the reach of
education to impoverished communities in
Africa and Asia so but how do you see
the fact that you're operating on a
non-commercial platform
reducing your scalability yeah so that's
a very good question and you know it's a
question you get in Silicon Valley a lot
that you know a not-for-profit doesn't
scale that you know
how are you gonna get the capital how
you're gonna track the talent all of
these questions and and and in my and I
think it's worth kind of clarifying it
just even what a not-for-profit is not
for profit essentially means no one owns
it the capital structure there's no
owner it's owned by society it can in
theory I mean our mission is to actually
give the content away for free but you
know Stanford is a not-for-profit you
can chart it they can generate revenue
what a not-for-profit says is all of
that revenue gets reinvested in the
business gets reinvested in the mission
while in a for-profit some gets
reinvested in the mission and some of it
can get dividend it out or stock
buybacks or whatever else so it's it's
it's a fundamental it's a capital
structure thing in terms of the access
to capital I mean it's a huge space I
mean just think about public education
is like a trillion dollars a year you
think about how much the Gates
Foundation alone spent almost a billion
dollars a year and us so there there are
people philanthropist many people in
Silicon Valley who got their capital
someone this is what they care about
they want to invest in education
especially if there's a high social
return and anyway you run our
spreadsheets you know our total invested
capital to date is less than three
million dollars and we're reaching
four-and-a-half million students per
month this time mixture it might be
twenty million three years might be a
hundred million students and the
contents not going all we can only
improve on it so it's it's an infinite
social return the other question this
was a question that we actually took
very seriously is can we attract the
talent you know there's no lottery
ticket at the Khan Academy you're
working here there's not a stock often
that you can become a billionaire we do
try to pay very competitive salaries in
Silicon Valley it was like can we
attract the best talent and it was an
open question I would say about six
months ago but what we've seen in the
past actually we saw this before the
first we've seen this throughout is not
only can we attract good talent we're
attracting the best talent I don't know
if y'all saw the press release the
number one employee Google just joined
us and I mean you know I guess he can
afford to do what he likes but but we're
getting we're getting the best talent
even people who aren't independently
wealthy yeah I mean our lead engineer
Ben came in she was a head engineer at
fog creek software Jolan software our
lead designer the head designer there we
got the head of high frequency trading
from one of the top hedge funds in the
world is now our head of analytics we
are getting shot and who's our president
was about to make partner at McKinsey I
mean these are the the the best talent
out there and what would you realize and
there's actually been psychological
studies on this is that people are
happiest and they're the most
productive and you'll get the best
talent you take money off the table you
do have to pay enough that they can live
they can get a mortgage they can buy
their Honda Accord and all the rest but
you take that off the table you don't
have to pay millions you just to pay a
good I would say upper middle class
salary in Silicon Valley and if you get
if you do that if you have
intellectually satisfying work and they
have a mission to pursue they'll be the
most productive people on the planet and
we're actually seeing that the people
that were the resumes that we're getting
the the the energy level in the company
it's better than any hedge fund we've
worked at it's better than any
management consulting firm that many of
our teams have worked at it's just it's
it's kind of been an unbelievable
experience so we're feeling pretty good
about you know we're in unchartered
waters there's only a few I would say
highly scalable not-for-profits out
there you know Wikipedia is kind of in
that space Kiva's in that space we're in
there Mozilla Foundation we're all kind
of in there we're all a little bit
different but I think we are facing
there's an inflection point in society
where there's a space for these type of
outcall of new institutions to emerge hi
I'd like to ask a question about a
phrase you used that's near and dear to
my heart because I taught the subject
for 12 years in high school how many
people here are familiar with
project-based learning
you heard yeah yeah okay good good
Theodore sizer Brown University
basically this is a nutshell description
students go in-depth into a subject by
showing what they understand about
science and math as it is applied to a
real-world situation and since you
mentioned that phrase I was just
wondering what you might be doing about
developing it yeah an adjunct for
students that turn around learn a
subject and then teach it to others
through absolutely so right now I think
you know the whole education debate is
actually slightly distorted you have one
camp where they say all we need more
open-ended project-based learning and
then you have another camp saying oh
well if you do that our kids aren't
gonna do well in the SAT and they're not
gonna do well in the state exams we have
to do more traditional academic a lot of
problem-solving a lot of traditional
types of problems and I think there's
two issues I think one on the
project-based learning side projects in
and of themselves there's a huge
spectrum of what they can be at one
spectrum they can be very cookie cutter
paint-by-numbers you know kind of stuff
that a lot of us might have done in
elementary school whatever and at the
other spectrum they can be hugely
open-ended they could be you know
starting a business painting a picture
building a robot inventing something
whatever
and and so what we see as our rule is
our role is I think a lot of what I've
just got we can be a catalyst for
freeing up physical human time and we
think the best use of that is broadly
described as project-based learning but
what we are seeing is now that you free
up this time it's actually becoming some
teachers immediately they say oh this
there's things that I've always wanted
to do at this time and I can now do it
but there's a lot of teachers saying wow
this is kind of scary what do I do with
this extra time now in the classroom and
and so we're exploring that and and and
what we're saying is it shouldn't even
be one class anymore let's explore the
boundaries what every student learns at
their own pace why them by age group why
separate calculus from physics from art
from history from statistics have them
all happening at the same time why have
a bell ring every 55 minutes why be
afraid to go deep in a subject because
you're going to miss class all of these
things shouldn't be questions anymore
and so we're we're pushing the envelope
with as many existing schools as
possible there's a school in Los Angeles
the Marlborough school that is a
Marlboro Academy that is actually doing
that they have 7th through 12th grade
girls all in the same class teaching
each other going back to the peer to
peer learning and and so far it seems to
be pretty profound next year they're
gonna double the number of students and
they're gonna double the number of
teachers but the teachers are going to
be in the same room together which is
also something that's kind of unheard of
in a traditional academic model and we
are bringing people on we're running a
summer camp this summer to explore what
can you do with the physical environment
like that risk game that I talked about
where kids are you know they're learning
what a market is and probability and all
of that what can you do in a physical
environment building robots starting
businesses whatever else and so what we
want to do is see the best practices
document them if we can make tools for
them so that can happen using a
classroom we want to build them or at
minimum Documentum so that other
teachers can can mimic them at any
anywhere in the world
thanks for being here I just wanted to
know what's your curriculum ideology if
there's any ideology behind your what
you doing and what as you've started
doing having doing these videos what do
you think that you're doing better than
say traditional teachers in the
classroom that makes kids get it faster
yeah so the ideology question this is
something I like to stress I don't think
there's one thing I said here that's
kind of new in terms of an idea I mean
the more that I talked to people the
more that I someone's been writing about
this hundred years ago
was been riding and there's even been
studies that people said well this
really worked and so some reason it gets
lost so I don't know exactly what the
idea ideology would be called I mean I
mean they're you know and it's very
scary when you label things because then
there's people in the other camp who
immediately try to you know if you say
that you are constructivist and they're
like oh constructivism where we need to
be but I would say it is a combination
of mastery based learning this idea that
you should learn things well you don't
have to be the absolute expert on
exponents before you do basic equations
but you should have a solid foundation
so that you don't get tripped up later I
would say highly influenced by
constructivist thinking that you really
do learn well when you explore things
but at the same time you have to relax
the tension that the world is assessing
you based on these exams and so we think
hopefully we can we can help do both at
the same time I think you know there's
kind of self-paced learning peer to peer
learning I mean whatever you want to
call it but I mean we're just trying to
do what kind of makes be practical about
it not not be too dogmatic about what
one or the other in terms of in terms of
in terms of kind of why the videos have
resonated with people it's an open
question I mean people comment on it I
think there's been a couple of things I
think it was really important that I
started off making them for my cousins
I think if in 2006 Bill Gates kind of
descended and and and and said Sal here
is X million dollars make some videos
that are gonna reach hundreds of
millions of people I probably would have
made things not too different than what
you get on a DVD from mcgraw-hill I
probably would have made these very
fancy computer graphics and as the next
stage in photosynthesis you know it
sound like your GPS device and and and
and and and the reason why those look
that way is because what a decision
makers superintendent or Eve sometimes
the teacher when anyone looks at it for
30 seconds like oh that's professional
that looks cool that's using computer
graphics and the decision makers are
never actually sitting down and saying
am I actually learning photosynthesis
here am i actually understanding
photosynthesis to actually feel a human
connection with this person and I think
what was neat early on for me is I was
like it was it was a human to human even
today when people watch the videos they
feel like I'm you know I'm their older
brother I'm their neighbor you don't see
my face faces are highly distracting
especially when they have a unibrow and
and so
and so you take that out so it really
feels it really feels like we're an
indian ray romano i sometimes been
referred to it but but but it really
feels like we're sitting next to each
other at the kitchen table the focus is
on the content you know the voice is is
kind of there I mean I've actually
gotten letters from people saying you
know when they normally think they think
in their own voice but as soon as they
see an equation they start hearing well
let's think about this now and they hear
this you know so I don't know I think
it's a conversation ality of it it feels
human it feels you know I think a lot of
Education material is made very top-down
that you know some group some politician
or executive says we need to make
content in this area then they go hire a
bunch of experts and I'm not being
disparaging of the experts but when you
have a crowd doing it together
they have fights on what the content
should be they should write they'll
write scripts and at the end they go and
find some teacher or somebody some to
pay and they pay them by the hour to
essentially read their script and that
whole process is saying the least
important thing in this process is the
actual content and what we're saying is
though the most important thing is I
mean even you know I'm the executive
director of the Khan Academy but I still
fan spend at least fifty percent of my
time making content because that's
what's going to resonate with students
we put a high priority on our developers
that are making actual content that
students are using we're not we're not
just all our strategy is everything
platform is everything the content is
what actually that's where the rubber
hits the road hey I'm an undergrad here
at Stanford and I was fortunate enough
to attend Montessori School for until
seventh grade and one of the strengths I
see of Montessori School is kind of
exactly what you're doing and letting
people go at their own pace so in second
grade I was already starting LG bra and
I could be at a totally different level
in reading and so I'm wondering you have
like for PhDs now and so I'm wondering
to what extent you've looked at existing
models like Montessori it's kind of like
his question was and to what extent
you're maybe working with Montessori
schools to kind of make Montessori
scalable when it's been criticized as
something that can only work in small
schools where teachers are highly paid
you know and I'm not an expert here I
mean you know
like a lot of people I always thought
Montessori was something that go through
you know pre-k and maybe kindergarten
and I've only started learning about
Montessori programs that go much deeper
and we've actually just been reached out
by Montessori I think they're K through
12 on the East Bay and I think they hear
a lot of what we're saying like wait
that's what we've been doing forever
that's what you know that's what
Montessori is about self-paced learning
kids teaching kids kids experimenting
with things and so yeah we're eager to
kind of and and you know we have a long
way to go we think we're in the
beginning of the first inning but a lot
of what we're talking about actually is
maybe the missing link in Montessori is
that yes the self-paced learning all of
that but how does the how do we know
that you're learning things or how can
we met you know or how does the teacher
have data to intervene properly well how
does a student know that they're
learning things and things like that and
so there's a certain level of you can
have a scaffold of kind of this type of
self-paced learning that I think makes
people more comfortable with the really
open-ended stuff so yeah I think they're
one in the same very very very
complementary how do you given that so
in creating the content for a con
economy you focus on academic subjects
like math here will teach you math in
extremely granular like patterns or will
teach you like biology or chemistry or
whatever so what why couldn't you extend
this to like nearly any other form of
human learning what yeah like I don't
know yes I I don't want to like think of
like I don't like I don't want to like
imagine Khan Academy as like some self
health course but why couldn't Khan
economy have a course on procrastination
oh yeah I have my daughter and my
daughter is now 7 months old my son is 3
years old and I was thinking because you
know right now I'm not that far from the
dating world I mean you know I'm still
pretty far but but you know if I give
hurt them advice now and we time shifted
so I like getting advice they'll take it
more so I you might see that type of
stuff but but what what that said you
know we actually I don't know if those
presentations still up yeah the next
slide we're actually we've started some
experiments with with the Stanford med
school and actually have some videos of
some of the stuff that we
we were playing with I mean it's just
purely experimentation there you go but
yeah but what we really want to want to
experiment what we want to do and I'll
show you these videos cuz they're kind
of fun I mean these were just kind of
just we just tried it out I just hung
out at the Med so there is a problem
right there at that Junction so at least
that part of drug kinetics we need to
understand how they penetrate different
parts of the body if we can get to those
patients and get them to skilled health
care both in the field and at the
hospital we can affect their outcomes
and what the the lamina connects to the
spinous process remember this is a drug
it didn't even touch the breast cancer
had a dramatic effect in the survival of
these young women right so again it just
makes us a whole new way of thinking
about disease yeah so what we're hoping
to do over there and you're gonna see it
hopefully over the next year is you know
I start with a lot of content we started
building this platform analytics and all
the rest for like hey that that can be
used by anybody and so hopefully over
the next year you're going to start
seeing other possibly major institutions
saying hey we can start offering courses
on this platform leveraging it in any
way she performed so I would love I mean
I don't know how many of y'all are a
diamond age Neal Stephenson yeah so I
would love this to be the young lady's
Illustrated primer where so the
lisaknott not the book is essentially
neo Victorian China you know it's highly
highly hierarchical Society this is like
you know in the future this this
nobleman wants to essentially get this
engineer to build like this the ultimate
learning platform for his granddaughter
the the the the engineer sees it's so
good that he builds a version for his
own daughter and it being China it gets
bootlegged and and and then it gets in
the hands of 200,000 orphan girls and
then they take over the planet so yes
that does be good outcome yeah we should
probably go for two more questions yes
we can yes two more questions better be
good thank you for speaking today so I'm
actually a first year medical student I
recognize dr. probers oh yes boys on
there and I'm meeting with some teachers
from the Children's Hospital school
tomorrow at Lucile Packard to see how
Khan Academy can be implemented one
because they are at times understaffed
and two it might be interesting to
assess the cognitive effects a certain
mints downstream so what I guess
guidelines or even cautionary notes
would you provide to people who are
looking to implement Khan Academy and
new settings but perhaps you know I knew
someone experimental way yeah no I mean
we think it's great I mean that's that's
the fun thing about you put it out there
and people are figuring out I mean
that's actually an example that we've
heard that people are you know when
children with these with these kind of
chronic diseases they're in the hospital
for months at a time they can learn now
we've heard of actually like child
athletes and actors using this because
once again there we actually heard about
prisoners I mean they're captive
audience I mean it's but but but but but
it's yeah yeah I mean I would say do it
if you hit road bumps I mean it should
be relatively self-service we're trying
to make it more self-service every day
but ping us you know I'm s con at
khanacademy.org you can look at our at
our our website emails if you have any
questions because our goal is just make
it a self-service as possible thank you
one more question so hypothetically if
someone were thinking about starting a
company in the EdTech space that bill
top-off built on top of but didn't
compete with Khan Academy so there seems
to be rhetorically a lot of excitement
around the potential for for individuals
to learn from Khan Academy and become
more confident their skills but in in
your talk what I saw a lot of excitement
from you about was your partnership with
schools in Los Altos schools and also
the school medicine here so I would say
I would ask for your vision for Khan
Academy let's say over the next five to
ten years to be realized who do you
think are gonna be some of your key
partners generally speaking and what
role do they have to play in kind of the
larger educational space in order for
Khan to really have the impact that you
wanted to have yeah no I mean I my
answer will probably change every week
to this but the general notion I mean I
think going into this last I think the
content providers I mean one of the fun
things for me about this job is I get to
kind of hopefully spend the rest of my
life learning and teaching things I mean
I'm already kind of you know and that's
a fun thing to do but I there's no way I
can
everything or even a fraction of
everything and so I think I think
catalyzing other people like dr. prober
and and other you know experts to to one
be willing to do this which i think they
are and also feel comfortable in this
type you know not the traditional
lecture but the more conversational
style maybe two people at the same time
so I think the content creators I think
and that's not just video it could be
exercise content it could be static
questions we're hoping to experiment
with maybe crowd sourcing of questions I
mean it's crazy that every teacher in
the country has a different set of
questions and that they want a comment
said they have to go pay someone money I
mean they should just be able to pool it
there should be analytics on it they
should be able to create you know kids
go into the computer lab and say give me
a test where every kid's gonna get
different questions but they're
statistically the same and the
distribution looks like this and there's
only a 5% chance that one kid doesn't
finish and bam it just happens that
should exist I mean there's nothing
scientifically implausible about that so
I think it's it's kind of the community
is what we're gonna have to leverage in
terms of in terms of kind of the key
partners I think there's an interesting
I think the major institution is that to
some degree research institutions that
we're hoping Khan Academy turns into a
platform for cognitive education
whatever type of research I mean yeah
you have two million kids doing problems
every day I mean that might be twenty
million problems done every day I you
could if you haven't better you know an
idea of how a better way for people to
conceptualize fractions and you have a
good way of measuring it we're already
doing a/b testing we put 5% of the
audience in front of that versus the
control see what it one day you have
your data for your PhD you I mean it
sounds crazy oh you are doing well you
could come by no we actually have a
postdoc from Stanford who's about to
come on board to do research on our on
our data so I think the research
institutions I think I think there's a
very interesting potential obviously
from a Content point of view with with
the Stanford's and the MIT s and of the
world I think the really
forward-thinking in I would say schools
of any you know age or demographic you
know whether it's small borough which is
an elite girl school in Los Angeles or
Eastside prep which is a highly
effective Chargers collector they're an
independent school but they're the cater
to a underserved demographic in East
Palo Alto I think those are going to be
key I think and I think it'll be
interesting I think employers will be
key too because I think at the end of
the day all of this I mean the end
you know people sometimes confuse the
end goal is happy and productive people
that's the end goal and I guess a
thriving democracy run by happy
productive people that's better
that's the end goal and and so I think a
lot of it is well let's just cut to the
chase how do we get to that end goal and
a lot of employers play a big role of
that how do we and and so you know
everything we've talked about is the
learning side but I think there's an we
could talk for another hour about it and
I put some videos on there if y'all are
curious about it but I think there's a
whole other dimension of Education which
is the credentialing side and I think
what we're in the process of seeing is
the two things are going to get
decoupled which will be a very good
thing
because it kind of liberate s-- the
learning to happen in whatever ways best
and then the credentials become stronger
signals because they're you know you you
guys Stanford everyone's you're gonna go
anywhere in the planet people are gonna
know Stanford yes you get an interview
but 99% of universities in the world you
spend the money you take the time you go
there even if you learn this stuff
tremendously you go to the next state
the next city and much less the next
country they're like what is this what I
don't understand what this is and so I
think the credentials could become even
more powerful kind of more recognize
things and and as that happens I think
you're going to see a lot of interesting
dynamics in education so we should
probably honor our commitment with you
that you get home and have some time
with your own family yes after spending
time with us we do have a small gift for
you knowing that you graduated from
Harvard Business School we wanted you
ever have a taste of the Stanford
business oh yeah so we have autographed
books by Jeff Pfeffer chip and Jennifer
rocker oh thank you and the requisite
Stanford swag all very good
[Applause]